the batman takes place in a brand new
version of gotham city which is
completely different to the one seen in
the dc extended universe features batman
vs superman justice league and birds of
prey matt reeves vision for the urban
jungle is very much a grimy dark place
where it always seems to be raining the
setting matches the equally moody new
version of batman who protects the
innocent from the hordes of criminals
who move through all corners of the city
when the riddler starts his war on
corruption within the ranks of gotham's
political financial and law enforcement
spheres bruce wayne has to dive head
first into a sprawling mystery that
stretches from the mayor's office to the
bowels of the seedy iceberg lounge the
riddler's brutal game reveals some
devastating truths about the city and it
even forces bruce to grapple with his
family's legacy
thomas and martha wayne's memories were
tarnished both in the eyes of the public
and bruce by the time the credits roll
mainly due to the riddler revealing
thomas wayne tried to keep the lid on
martha's mental illness treatment at
arkham asylum which ultimately spiraled
out to including carmine falcone none of
this matters to the citizens of gotham
who must fight for survival when the
riddler bombs the sea wall flooding most
of the city to make matters worse the
caped crusader has to battle a number of
the villains faithful followers inside
the roof of gotham arena as they try to
shoot crowds of survivors it's a
dramatic final battle that sees batman
fighting the riddler's violent ideology
as embodied by his followers and the
fight nearly gets the better of him but
thankfully the bat has a surprising
weapon in his utility belt during the
fight on the arena's railings things go
from bad to worse for the bat when he
ends up on his back after taking
numerous shots from riddler's followers
unfortunately one of the shooters takes
the opportunity to attack selena kyle
who tries to stop the gang from
committing mass murder
for a moment it looks like one of them
might kill her which causes bruce to
pull a small vial of green liquid out of
his utility belt and inject it this
green liquid gives batman a much needed
adrenaline boost energizing him to the
degree that he can save selena and
finish the battle for gotham's soul but
that mysterious liquid is never actually
addressed leaving us to wonder what
exactly the bat injected it's hard not
to see it as a nod towards the classic
villain bane dc fans will know that the
muscled behemoth uses a green formula
called venom to give him enhanced
strength and speed in a fight it
typically gives him a brutal edge over
his opponents not unlike the burst of
ferocious energy bruce gets in the final
showdown near the end of the batman this
leaves audiences with a few questions
that we annoyingly don't get the answers
to including has batman already crossed
paths with bane or is he out there in
the world waiting for his chance to
strike
will bane show up in a sequel to the
batman should that next movie ever be
greenlit
probably not the green liquid bruce
wayne uses in the final fight is not a
big enough easter egg to suggest the man
who broke the bat is coming to gotham
any time soon
plus matt reeves has already opened up
about what he'd like to do with a second
film if warner brothers gives him the
go-ahead and it doesn't sound like the
hulking figure is involved in the
director's vision in a recent interview
with collider reeves explained that when
it comes to dc characters he wants to
find the most grounded way of telling
their stories he went on to say he
already has an idea of how to adapt one
of the most iconic villains in batman's
rogues gallery mr freeze
plus after the riddler is safely in
custody he speaks with his next door
cellmate and while he never mentions a
name it's fairly obvious this character
played by barry kyogen is supposed to be
the newest version of the joker
so while this is great news for fans
wanting more from reeves contributions
to the dceu don't expect to see bane go
up against robert pattinson's version of
the caped crusader any time soon
now is not the time for fear
that comes later
with the director's grounded approach to
comic book storytelling it probably
wouldn't be a good idea to use bane
anyway since christopher nolan already
delivered a realistic version of the
villain played by tom hardy in 2012's
the dark knight rises
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
you